right-hander nathan avaldi
he's having himself a pretty good start
to the year 7-2 record 1.19 whip 65
strikeouts
that right arm has some electric stuff
his last couple of starts have been very
good for him
at home he has not been fared as well as
he has on the road boos for
jose altuve swinging in a fly ball left
center field
[ __ ] coming in on that and makes the
play for the first out
of the night so one out of no one on for
the shortstop carlos correa he's gonna
ground this one
two sharp hops gonzales up and over big
stretch there by santana
and two passed out two out nobody on for
alex bregman bregman shoots it down the
right field line racing back is renfro
it's over his head
bounces on the warning track and over
the low wall down the right field line
that's a double for bregman and alex
will stop at second base with his 13th
two packer of the year
two outs the astros have a man in
scoring position here's jordan alvarez
and that's a rocket into right field
bregman
[Music]
[Applause]
and a scintillating end to the top of
the first jake utters he takes the mound
for your houston astros
this is a place that jake has not fared
very well throughout his career
previous 10 starts at fenway 6-2-6
era danny santana leading things off
ball four santana's on quickly
rafael devers to bat next he'll sting
that one in center field
straw back and it's over his head
santana down to third and puts on the
brakes a double
for rafael devers so two runners in
scoring position and a guy hitting 396
on the year
with runners in scoring position at the
plate jd martinez
got a big out there for odarizi striking
out jd martinez
first down to the inning first strikeout
for rotorusi here's xander bogart's
scenario that alex cora has been
preaching a lot
about getting that man in with less than
two out
any way you can backing up alvarez to
the warning track he's got it tagging up
santana
he is in the score and the red sox
strike first tonight they lead it one to
nothing
devers remained at second and the batter
is hunter renfro
round ball through the open space a base
it'll bring in another run
on a renpro he's had a rather fine first
inning and a red sox lead at two to
nothing he's at first base for marwyn
gonzalez swinging and a miss
got him on a breaking ball away gonzalez
strikes out second punch out of the
inning for odor rizzy
renfro and hernandez with an opportunity
to
make the play on the warning track but
it dropped in and a big break for
houston
see if the astros can capitalize on that
now it's miles strong
that's hit in the air shallow right
field and that's going to drop in fair
in front of renfro
and then bounces into the stands that'll
score a run as tucker comes home
and it's 2-1 boston the astros take
advantage of that previous miscue
it's altuve leading things off with
boston leading 2-1
he does have two career home runs
against nathan altuve drives one deep to
left field
this game is tied jose altuve
home run number 10. he clears the
stadium
and it's a 2-2 game correa moves to
second bring up
jordan alvarez that ball's roped over
the head of the first baseman santana
into the corner that will score correa
astros take a three to two lead jordan
alvarez
in with a double that's already the
fourth double for the astros and their
fifth extra base in
julie ropes one to left and the birthday
boy has an rbi with a base hit down the
left field line
yuli guriel makes it up four to two game
this lineup is relentless michael
brantley trying to join the hit parade
and he does he ropes the ball in the
right center field
hill comes healey and that's an rbi
single for brantley
it is five to two the astros rolling
here in the third
that'll load them up for yulie guriel
better than
500 average with the bases loaded in his
career it's his birthday right now he
had an rbi double in the third one for
two
and a ground ball yanked to raffy devers
he hesitated a bit but he does gun into
second in time
and nathan navalny works his way out of
it oda rizzy on the mound
will face xander bogarts of the red sox
to lead things off he's our cleanup man
swing high
deep drive left field that one's going
to carry back it goes and gone
home run for xander bogart's number 11.
red sox battling back that makes it 5-3
oda rizzy who had a very tough time
through his first five starts of this
season on three with an era of more than
seven coming in
up and down ride tonight gave up two
runs early on looks like the red sox
might have a big night against them the
first two men reached in the first
inning and scored
for the last four guys in their lineup
are over santana sends one high
and deep to center field straw near the
wall but he has room and puts it away
in front of the center field wall for
the final out of the inning so jake
after those two runs of the first inning
has now retired 13 out of the last 14
batters
they divaldi still out there even though
he's giving up five runs on 11 hits oh
two to correa
swung on and missed he put him away on a
breaking ball he
fandom two gone and alex corbett will
take the ball from his starter
last inning and a foul ball now watch
the fan with the big bright
shirt on he's got it all lined up and
bang
right off the top of the head oh and
he's got a big red mark
over there too i love the smile
so straw now bats with the infield in
and one out second and third chance to
add to this 5-3 lead
straw sends one into right field
tagging at third is michael brandley
lining it up his rent row here comes
brantley to try to score and he will be
safe at home plate close play brantley
scores on the sac fly by mile straw it's
now
6-3 11 hits for correa in his last 26
at bass so he's on with one out for
bregman bregman drives one deep to left
field
all the way back and gone home run
caught by an astros band
in the monster seats of breggy bomb at
fedway
and the astros lead eight to three
bottom of the ninth inning christian
javier
has thrown three innings of scoreless
relief retiring nine of the ten he's
faced
and it'll be jd martinez to start the
home ninth
and that's hit in the air on the infield
altuve
to his right now to his left on the
infield dirt makes the catch that's out
number one
one out no one on for xander bogart
swing and a miss
as bogarts chase the fastball off the
plate away that's the third strikeout
for javier
and the red sox are down to their final
out last hope for boston's hunter renfro
lifted left side on the infield coming
in as bregman on the grass still coming
in makes the catch
and that is the ball game the houston
astros take the first two in boston
winning this one tonight by a final of
eight to three
astros have won three in a row